and we don't seem to have ever gotten
back to that basic idea of human
progress did you watch that video that
went viral recently on Twitter where
it's a high school workout in 1962 and
all the young men are yeah like
basically in boot camp yeah they're
they're doing man they're they're
swinging from those bars on what they're
called like they're they're holding
their own body weight monkey bars it's
not monkey bars they're they're they're
they're vertical yeah they're vertical
wow Ian wow I really dropped the ball on
that one really just but man you can
stream man yeah we we roll in polls I I
don't I don't I don't know what happened
to this country but I kind of feel like
the night is always darkest before the
dawn and so as long as you are working
on being selfish
[Music]
the nutty's always darkest before it
becomes orange before I mean that's
that's actually a really interesting
thing you just mentioned the dawn is
orange and so is the done